hi everyone i'm jordan octane the
producer and co-director of the short
film grit and i'm here to guide you
through the must use of producing your
own sad short film
before you get started you want to have
a really great script what story are you
telling and what message are you sending
to the world for example with our film
grit when I read the script I knew it
was something I wanted to direct and
produce because it was really witty it
was really funny and because it was an
inspiring story about women choice and
motherhood as a filmmaker those are the
types of stories I want to put in the
world have a story that aligns with your
vision as a filmmaker
next you'll want to secure your
production team you must have a producer
who is resourceful and thorough when
researching the rules and guidelines
within the sag process
ask your filmmaker friends for
recommendations for production people
our budget allows a production team with
a producer co-producer and production
manager
next you'll want to file your sag
paperwork in order to produce a sack
project you must have a qualified
signatory who produces the film your
producer can be the signatory or you can
create a separate business like an LLC
or a DBA you'll want to consult a lawyer
or a tax professional as to the pros and
cons of each keep in mind that whomever
ends up being the SAG signatory will
technically own the rights to the film
once it's complete take the time to
learn the difference between a short
film contract and the new media contract
and decide what's best for your
production hint it will depend on what
you choose for your primary distribution
purchase workman's compensation
insurance for your production sag
requires your talent to be covered and
it's very important
hire a payroll company for your caste
sag has specific guidelines you want to
follow him when it comes to covering all
the union fees and ensure everyone's
safety
I highly recommend you get to know the
sag rules regarding short films and
create a professional working
environment for everyone on set have an
amazing shoot and happy shooting